what was the most expensive piece of
jewelry you ever bought mike
listen right you had the gold chains
yeah but
yeah um yeah i bought a gold chain for
like seven million dollars
wait wait a gold chain
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot box and i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson
mike we got an awesome guest today
brother oh and we've been killing the
guest lately i know
great people coming in here jim jones
welcome back
thank you thank you thank you the whole
process
diplomatic community okay
all right how y'all feeling we're
feeling pretty awesome man
good what do you want to listen well
what are you doing here tell us about
this
product saucy a part of uh marijuana
company called saucy um
my partner alex he's out there paulie um
where alexa alex don't talk oh come on
[ __ ] i'm alex
hey good good people come hang out with
us what's up
alex say what's up alex what's up what's
up don't be scared
[ __ ] just you want to
if you're good you're are you good yeah
i'm good okay just hang out here with
your guys yeah
smoke one yeah smoke smoking is good man
so tell me about the company tell us
where the sauce what was the company um
local extra yeah
yeah we're in cali right now we're in
oregon as well
uh we got one of the the largest growth
facilities in oregon right now we got a
couple of
we got one of the we got a couple of big
manufacturing facilities here in la
uh we do all different types of products
edibles
blunts as you can see this is really
good thank you man appreciate it yeah
that's actually the first jim that's
jim's that's jim's line
he owns he has his own product line capo
which is going to develop into that's
his first product that's the blunts
keith blunts that's the first legal
blunt on the market it's not tobacco
it's rolled in
tea leaf to have the same type of
tobacco effect
and i love that so that's his first
product and we're very excited about it
we just launched it
and we think we're going to kill it with
it i love that man great packaging
i love that wrapped in tea leaves
appreciate that yeah
we've been working like for the last two
years just on
r d and just make perfecting the
products and making sure everything that
we put into the product is the absolute
absolute best how did you guys meet
um mutual friend of rock nation um og
awesome man yeah so pick up the og one
yeah oh gee [ __ ] one that's
right
that's our guy jim have you wanted to
get
oh get away if you can when you when you
talk
um close to that mic but um have you
wanted to get into the cannabis business
for a while
um was it pretty natural well i wasn't
i had it wasn't on my plan on my agenda
um when og bring it to my attention and
me and alex sat down and
it made perfect sense for all the weed
that i smoke and
for the years the different types of all
the money we paid for this [ __ ]
oh definitely that too yeah yo we got
what what is that a lot of research
what do we smoke a month is what is it
forty thousand a month
we switch forty thousand dollars we
smoked ten tons of weed at the ranch
a month isn't that crazy
that's crazy it's crazy
that's non-stop every second we right
there like that's a lot
but um but we throwing out and the
dispensaries like
what was it 500 500 a month
ain't nothing wrong with that 100 500 a
month i'm a
doubt this is a great market to be in
like the the money is phenomenal
i can't believe me doing this i can't
believe i'm talking to you smoking on
the [ __ ] pocket this is like a
[ __ ]
god because i was [ __ ] up before all
this weed [ __ ] i was
[ __ ] up man yeah me too i was
this [ __ ] [ __ ] beautiful man just see
you like whoa this shit's starting all
over again
they said i've seen today they said you
building a a a weed resort
yeah brother absolutely i got
acres there go right there's the
blueberry acres man
and we're gonna make this desert hot
springs palm springs
oasis in the [ __ ] desert man it's
right there on the tin highway
on one side we're gonna have what we
have um
you know i mean the golfing [ __ ] there
we're going to have
um you could just wave while you buy
your golf
absolutely chilling at the pool cannabis
friendly my friend
canvas friendly resort man wellness
center
cannabis centric wellness center
alternative health care
one acre one acre long um lazy river
a wave pool you got wave pools you could
[ __ ] surf you could bring your
surfing board you could surf up there
yeah we got shadows
you won't even know you're in california
you think you're in the bahamas
somewhere
[ __ ] back in february we had the
first event there which was mike's kind
festival
some of your boys are you down with um
the fergs and them right yeah ferguson
um performed for us all right that's
dope that's dope to the asap
the family man they got mad love from us
man they blew us up
after watching him perform i realized
listen because i brought miguel to
perform two for me and then i watched
the track
whoa i can't bring no more r b guys here
you gotta keep it gotta keep that energy
up gotta keep that energy up cause they
didn't i thought they were gonna love
mcnaughton it was the rap guy ferg had
him
[ __ ] going crazy 7 500 people going
mad that's a lot of people
but we playing for four thousand but 7
500 came
that's a lot of weed being burnt there
one time yeah and actually it was
beautiful man planning for 50
000 in the next one in october police
were there
it was so cool to see do you still have
another one thank you
this is not the video
now what's up with young bucks sad love
story life story i mean
what is that
i ain't nothing
y'all know ben baller mm-hmm he got good
[ __ ]
it's my guy yeah he's not coming yet did
he make that for you
no any of your pieces well alex i come
from the jewelry business
cool alex is one of the biggest jewelers
well in new york yeah we're right there
on jewelry lane all the [ __ ] be
hanging out there and [ __ ]
that was a trip right you go there with
some
what was the most expensive piece of
jewelry you ever bought mike
some listen right
you're the gold chains yeah but yeah
um yeah i bought a gold chain for like
seven million dollars
wait what a gold chain no diamond champ
sorry
a dime a chain for seven m's yeah
i was his jeweler at that time i was
telling somebody
see you like you you you a legend and
your stories are all legends so
all the stuff that i come up uh come up
uh just hearing and and so no but listen
i was just wrecking my stole that [ __ ]
none of them you know that was nothing i
had lots of juries and [ __ ] i used to
give away
yo mike i seen you in the tunnel i want
to say i was in high school i want to
say i was like 16.
i was like 16. this might have been like
94.95 i was like 16 17. 95
yeah i was locked up then 95 i came home
yeah it was 95 then you was in there
with a silk shirt on
half buttoned down with the biggest bra
i diamond bracelet ever seen in my life
but she wasn't with nobody he was
walking through that [ __ ] by herself and
that whole tunnel was part and like the
red sea it was like the movies
[ __ ] did not want no sauce with mike
[ __ ] act like [ __ ] like whoa [ __ ]
mike
the whole the whole tunnel
listen i used to live a really dark life
back then and [ __ ]
and i mean i'm so happy that it's over
oh no
he was looking good man yeah
young kids perspective watching the real
superhero walk through the crowd that
[ __ ] is real inspiring you know thank
you brother thank god
i don't know just i was consumed with
the [ __ ] music the music had
everybody [ __ ] up back then right rap
had everybody
[ __ ] up wow jim was that the first
time you ever saw mike
in person yeah yeah like that was uh
that's 95 that's when i first came home
yeah you know i mean but he was always
in my neighborhood like
zip and all i'm like i'm from i had an
opinion coupe up there
yeah 115th street when
when were the diplomats created when was
that
uh when did that what that was in the
late 80s was that no
diplomacy yeah i was high school so
i started in the late 90s cam first got
his deal like 98.
then the diplomat started like 2001
after we saw a
rockefeller and after that is history we
went for broke
hey listen you know what what happened
to damon dash man we
we're getting ready to get damon on the
show too how's he doing man is he cool
i couldn't tell you how damaged no i
don't think that's your man though
i don't i don't have a personal
relationship with dame like that anymore
[ __ ] yeah we all come to our crossroads
in life no
we don't you know what i mean you know
one time in life i would have hang out
with the crew you think i was gonna die
with you that the next thing you know
what happened to
it'd them like that man everybody
everybody changes as time goes not to
say there's nothing wrong with that
you know i mean you need different
people in your space sometimes
yeah you know sometimes the people you
grew up with
are more toxic than people that you meet
today
you know yeah and the people that you
meet today are more trustworthy
than the people that you grew up with
for all your life yeah i always that
makes sense this is it
i used to hear that all the time i was i
always was told this by wise and
everyone that you
fight is not your enemy and everyone
that helps you is not your friend
yeah you know and sometimes that that
goes with family too
you know sometimes it's just it doesn't
work with family i love you your mother
is my mother but this [ __ ] is not
working
we're not clicking we should click with
them it's not working
yeah exactly coming into the nfl they
would say
everyone who is with you to get you here
isn't necessarily going to be here with
you
you know on the way through because they
can't be you know
like they serve their purpose they serve
their purposes it just sounds so cold i
just sound cool
they serve their purpose but they can't
survive any longer any if they follow
you any further than nothing but
they're in the way um yeah
in the way yeah
i'm still stuck with that seven million
dollar change yeah
oh listen imagine this imagine i'm a
young guy right
and i got these [ __ ] i got um i come
out of prison i got like
hundreds of millions of dollars out of
person [ __ ] chilling that contracts
already already paid me up front million
just a million
and i just got out of prison right i'm
just going crazy so but
i'm buying the jury i'm buying these
houses i'm buying these cars i'm getting
these planes and stuff
but i'm still um just buying planes too
yeah right i'm still bitter
i'm still bitter and still better the
more i buy the more i buy and can't
satisfy i can't save my
[ __ ] appetite it's just [ __ ] um
spinning this stuff
you know you can satisfy so when i can't
get satisfied
spending enough and i can't go broke
fast enough i start destroying myself
and that gets me high that gets my dick
hard because nobody could do it but me
you get that yeah
yeah that's that's deep that's deep
the money can't buy you happiness no
it's not as [ __ ] that's not meant
to give you happiness money's not meant
for that stuff anybody said that's
what it's meant for is lying yeah it's
really what it's just
it's just a simple fact it's mentally
it's taking care of your friends and
your family
you know for the future and stuff making
sure they're never going to be like they
were before and stuff
but it's just that you know i mean if
you do anything else you're not doing
that's just what it's for
you know and help other people you know
you always have to do that because
that's what life's about helping people
and [ __ ] because that's where we come
from [ __ ] hands-outs and [ __ ]
that's just what life's about let's
[ __ ]
fly that's dope as [ __ ] man good listen
right
um thanks brother i'm 50 what i'm 52
going to 53
love brother the smoke is [ __ ] with
you you okay why are you leaving us
he wants to go get comfy but listen
when you get 52 you say boom we ain't
gonna see another 52 years
[ __ ] what about that you know you come
to the fact that my mortality is
at stake eventually you know i'm gonna
see that [ __ ] rim
that grim reaper and you say [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is almost over how do you feel
about this [ __ ] it's almost over i think
about it a lot too i try to i try to
i try to block it out because how do you
block it yeah it's hard no way
this is tough because when you get by
yourself is when that [ __ ] all hits you
like man
it's sooner or later it's just not it's
the kids are getting bigger you think
what the [ __ ]
my son's 16 now that blew my mind every
time i see him come in the kitchen and
[ __ ] like that like
another man in the house right for real
like yo
now this is a whole this is a whole trip
man so you
what you just said is crazy because we
think about all the stories that they
tell us about you that we thought was so
cool
all the flash it in in the hood that we
kind of glamorize and [ __ ] like that
handle that that was
more than i can handle i couldn't handle
that i couldn't
listen i couldn't handle the love the
love real honest love from people that
she was too overwhelmed i had never
experienced anything like that before
if anybody smiled at me i would punch
them in their face with you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know you stupid [ __ ] that's how i
knew your kid in brooklyn was born
[ __ ] you looking at me like that for
this that you're some stupid [ __ ]
i couldn't take these people not knowing
me it's hugging me kissing me it's
loving me oh
i love you the time bank bike mike oh
[ __ ]
yeah almost went insane couldn't take
that [ __ ]
the love almost drove you crazy no it
did drive me crazy
yeah you don't know how to perceive love
if you never really had it before yeah
what's this [ __ ] about i don't know you
you white [ __ ] i don't get away
hey [ __ ] hey you chinese [ __ ]
get away what the [ __ ] i didn't
understand you it's just weird they're
all around you get that [ __ ]
so how you start understanding it all oh
i suffered a lot of pain
a lot of lawsuits hitting people get the
[ __ ] away boom
you know fans this just fighting that i
had to be
realized that [ __ ] i know i'm a glutton
for pain but all these [ __ ] checks
i'm writing is really killing me
you know people you know some guy that
never had a nine to five nights they
know he got seven million dollars six
million dollars here
for me and i was here five million
dollars here for lawsuits
just because i couldn't handle it it was
panicking and [ __ ]
and when i panicked i just started
fighting [ __ ] the only [ __ ] i
know used a bunch of [ __ ]
around me you're the greatest we love
you nothing can stop you yes and that
you know
you're still one of the coolest [ __ ]
on the place of the planet though i tell
you that i don't know
absolutely you do it's effortless i
don't think you try at all you're just
you you're just being you
you're you're a figure in our lifetime
that it would never and and lifetimes to
to go we will never be forgotten like
what you did what you did in the game is
like what michael jordan did and what
you
what you did for us is a culture just
[ __ ] you still for a lot like
you don't back down you never kneel down
you always stood up and you always were
strong hey that sometimes
[ __ ] killed me too man sometimes i
wish i could imagine what the [ __ ] i say
that [ __ ] foreign
but somebody has to do that man somebody
has to be the one that
you know is the pillar
yeah the pillar is always the one that
gets the most you know they could tell
them to get up they get it all because
you just opened up the lane yeah exactly
but i can remember like at one time and
stuff [ __ ] i couldn't get a job nobody
would give me a job especially after
fighting this
so i just hung out with my friends that
we just partied yeah you know everybody
all the other friends had big
endorsements and this
and then they saved their money and my
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
and then um i just never gave up in life
you know that was just
i refuse to just give up in life and i
had an ego too my ego wasn't crushed yet
you know so i had the most i had more
journey to go because i needed that ego
to be crushed first
you know and i thought come on
i guess i'm here i guess i hear i guess
i try to surrender my ego and stuff from
the toad and
i guess this is why i'm here and this is
why everything's going good and
we're doing what we're doing and it's on
i think we're gonna do tyson records too
i think we're
going to go for it yeah [ __ ] yeah
hey listen anybody that wants to be
involved with tyson record
you know frenchie fred frenchy
come in here come in
i had a conversation with somebody about
their likes
i know we got something about that cause
we're getting that over again
now fred frenchy tell anybody anybody
that wants to um start a
music career acting for anybody that
wants to be involved has great talent
with especially music at that you'll be
starting tyson record to
um frenchie please talk to people and
tell them who to call it
guys that was just natural like to have
mike uh
rebuilding like tyson records number
like you know two part two actually
because if you guys didn't know mike had
uh timberland
tell them who you are before listen
right listen listen what happened let me
tell them let me tell you where i i come
from prison right
i spent some time in new york so i'm in
my car and i'm going up
i'm gonna drive to cleveland so before i
go to cleveland i go to rochester
buffalo somewhere up there and hang out
with devonte so
i didn't see the boss he came and
visited me a couple of times while i'm
in prison so i said i'm gonna come see
my man
right so he came and seemed to know i'm
going up there i'm upstate new york
and i see him in the studio and so we're
in the studio i've been talking to you
and he tells me he's saying like mikey i
see a bunch of kids you know
and i'm in the studio and they say mike
listen um
i'm giving you all these guys these guys
are you they're yours i said well i
don't want these [ __ ] what do
you mean you're giving me these people
what the [ __ ] do you mean what am i
going to do with these
he said no mike these are all stars and
i didn't look timbaland that looked like
no [ __ ] star to me [ __ ]
um genuine didn't look like no [ __ ]
stuff missy ellie didn't like no [ __ ]
started me
um tweet didn't look like no [ __ ]
star to me i have to get the
so my my impersonation of what a star
should look like is [ __ ] diana ross
at that time 1995 i'm out of prison a
star looked like [ __ ] diana
ross
whitney [ __ ] houston right so
davonte never told me davonte ain't
never [ __ ] tell me
that the star like diana ross and them
look like these people at one time
i ain't never know that [ __ ] you feel me
now do you understand what i'm saying at
one time this is supposed to brief you
like this
is the new thing that's going on at one
time diana ross and
the supremes look like these dirty
little [ __ ] right so he said
nah mike alright so he said mike they're
you and i'm giving them to you i said
man you ain't go give me these
[ __ ] okay the ones i can't do
this [ __ ]
i didn't want 20 months listen they had
people with them
right and so the water said no mike
these are all yours i'm giving them to
you this is a lot of money that's not
i don't see this [ __ ] them aren't they
right now
i'll take these let's go out and eat
let's just take everybody out to eat so
get
into the best restaurant we fed these
guys back like they never they were just
young street kids like i was
right next thing i know these
[ __ ] on the top of the charts
they ring they got half a billion
dollars worth of [ __ ] i said [ __ ] this
[ __ ] was right
i should have been in the music business
you see the bottom line that mike knows
who's the star he is now
yeah you know he actually knows who's
there
[ __ ] devonte gave me these [ __ ]
let me just take them out to eat man
they don't look like they [ __ ] ate in
a month all right so i think
so we went to the best restaurant and
but no accident cena
we went to the best [ __ ] restaurant
and we yes um
we went out and he had treated the name
never eaten like that before
that's amazing i was looking at all
these mothers and [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
wow right hey tyson records coming
no that's really that's serious hit fred
french
mike oh yeah
saturday
and don't forget to ship out those
hoodies
to our fans
how do i know who this goes
this is not what i do
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
hey evan what's up i'm not gonna get the
hoodies out in time man
evan i'm busy okay i'm at a photo shoot
all right
try shipstation.com ship station
right now hotbox and listeners can try
shipstation
free for 60 days when you use promo code
hotboxing there's absolutely no risk
you can start your free trial without
even entering your credit card info
so use code hot boxing and get your ship
together at shipstation.com
yeah that's how it was that's how i met
all these guys i'm from prison he goes
hey mike they're all you i said what the
[ __ ] you mean all might i want to take
it i didn't want to take care of my crew
i had
now i got [ __ ] 12 other people to
take care no mike they're yours they're
all stars
i don't know this is some [ __ ]
devonta getting high and [ __ ]
i had no idea these [ __ ] turned
out to be stars
that's amazing and we're looking for
other talented guys some guys could be
some italian coordinators are [ __ ]
the people that go out and find these
people but i guess they got [ __ ]
under youtube now we don't need [ __ ]
people to go out and find people huh
we don't need that that's what life is
based about
on our society is just to alienate
everybody it's
work with our phones that's what steve
jobs did
he must ask somebody for directions or
something and somebody must have said
[ __ ] you
he said well i'm never going to hear
that again oh no serious really
no no all right
these white intellectual smart not
really intellectual ones but the muslims
that are
geeky their eyes these guys that build a
[ __ ] robot to kick everybody's ass
they got bad negative thoughts and [ __ ]
you'd be surprised what somebody could
create around here
they've already done that they got
robots that could do push-ups
[ __ ] jump over a building yeah [ __ ]
like that it's crazy oh [ __ ]
it is [ __ ] mean hey listen i know you
would love this since you gonna be
rapping and [ __ ] and you still make used
to rap yes
i just dropped the project the other day
called capo no
do you know it [ __ ] rain diamonds and
certain planets like jupiter and [ __ ]
what it rains diamonds
you believe that [ __ ] they tell you
right that should tell you it's true you
believe it right
if that but that machine that [ __ ] that
these [ __ ] these geeks may
tell you it's true you'll believe it i
don't know if it's true but this geek
[ __ ] told me was true
and it's on empty
no i don't know if this is true i don't
want to believe this [ __ ] that's why
they send these planets
knowing they'll send those those those
little ships up to mars and [ __ ]
and they land and they wake up diamonds
yeah all this time
that's crazy put that in your rap [ __ ]
[ __ ] ain't gonna know about that
that's dope chunks of diamonds may be
floating in hydrogen helium
deep in the [ __ ] atmosphere
satin [ __ ] jupiter
yeah yeah white people before i save me
up they're raining diamonds
how do we get that so they send their
ship up there they landed on mars and
they start digging
no i'm serious they got machines they
yeah we send machines up there because
we can't breathe the [ __ ] die so the
machine hits
it lands and it starts digging and sucks
all the minerals off the ground
i'm telling you yeah now i'm a third
grade fourth grade dropout and i know
this [ __ ]
because of this [ __ ] internet yeah i
would have never known that [ __ ] can you
imagine they say they want to send us
over there before we can
get more space because it's over
properly no they want some money over
here when it gets overpopulated here
we get [ __ ] population control we
kill people oh no we definitely going to
space
yeah you see they had the rocket that
lands
this way yeah yeah yeah that's space
level right there it lands and then they
start digging don't talk about notes and
then it goes back to the no
what i'm saying know how a rocket takes
off yeah yeah
it takes off straight and then it lands
same way it took off yep so that's
travel so now we can get inside it
should take off and it's going to land
right here
flight 233 just gotta get off that
[ __ ] take care i wanna
do that though yeah i don't want to i
don't
i wanna die here i wanna stay right here
rich or poor i wanna die right here
alone
do that though you ain't gonna take a
one trip up this he was popping up there
one time
i don't think i don't want to i want to
just chill here and die here
you don't even want to just do one time
i want to take too much time and take
you 30 years to get there
no i don't think it's going i don't
think they oh man 30 years to get there
yeah it got to be a closer planet than
that
no bars is the closest it takes you
really long time
mars is the closest and any other planet
is mostly the unknown
oh man can you believe this too what's
the what's the um the most powerful
win we had in the one storm here uh
over 200 miles an hour yeah check out
fannin's wins and [ __ ] this is one of
those rockets landing
yeah this is what you were
they let elon musk do [ __ ] anything
that should go be at delta in a minute
delta flight 929 going to mars the mars
i think first
boarding and first flight is going to be
a lot of old people say well i got
nothing to lose anyway
let's try it [ __ ] you guys anyway let's
go
try this [ __ ] like what were you saying
for me to bring up
um [ __ ] i forgot what it was god damn it
we we have you stuck i'm stupid
that's the medical benefits when
yes i believe theirs is like [ __ ] ten
thousand miles rip you tear you apart
you know it's like it's like paper like
the wind now you take paper and fly if
that's human being the boom rotate your
part
that's why we can't live nowhere but
here at least that's what they tell us
imagine we live on a flat [ __ ] world
all this time we thought we lived on a
round planet huh
we have no [ __ ] evidence to believe
that we're around planned only but
people telling us but we really don't
know 11 where we came from who the [ __ ]
is on purpose here i'm not going to go
you're not going to tell me that little
real planet though how do you know that
you've never been out of space
over a thousand a thousand one thousand
one hundred and eighteen miles per hour
the win yeah so that would tear us apart
yeah just ripped through three hundred
two hundred
yeah 200 miles an hour taking you all
over the place
imagine i'm saddening something like
that
can you imagine being on a planet that
has [ __ ] snow and rain diamonds
you probably it's been liquid diamonds
it's liquid but it's
once it lands it freezes doesn't it
mm-hmm
i don't know yeah you have to once a
week to reach your [ __ ] atmosphere
yo it's [ __ ] insane [ __ ] my whole
brain up right y'all just got me going
in so many directions right there oh you
want to see some really cool stuff i eat
you know the sentinel island where the
savages haven't left it for like 60 000
years their family's been there and
since they came from africa
and somewhere in india and some of them
left and someone said we're gonna stay
here they've been there for 60 000 years
it's a bunch of black small
[ __ ] they're little people
i'm serious and they killed a bunch of
[ __ ] trying to [ __ ] with them
recently right oh show them they killed
people it was in the news and [ __ ]
these bible guys lord jesus loves you
buddy
[ __ ] spears oh jesus
oh man you guys see this [ __ ] yeah it's
called north sentinel island see this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
look wait get the way they killed the
[ __ ] though
look how little it is
and where's this [ __ ] american killer
yes they
got it there right isolation stop
[ __ ] with
[ __ ] you got to go there prepared say
i'm the one the guy they don't need to
be
pleased we need to make all these guys
ella cool j was that he disagreed with
me he said we should lead these people
alone
[ __ ] that they don't kill some people
too we gotta investigate these more they
may got some gold over there anyway
they killed a bunch of [ __ ] we
gonna leave them alone now
they killed the americans [ __ ]
american white mother well he's
halfway but they killed him and they
should be [ __ ] look right there this
good looking guy right here this [ __ ]
look at this poor guy this guy's a good
my understanding that there was
what bringing christians right tribal
groups
but he says missionary was traveling in
a group of missionaries
and adventures my understanding is that
he was there
to bring christianity to this remote
group said king
if you're a believer your worldview is a
non-believers uh
lost and their only hope is jesus
that's what he thought i believe that
too they need that police officer vijay
singh
the golfer also a police officer
said the killing apparently occurred
saturday on north sentinel island
i mean they just threw a spear through
his chest and dr
drug them into the fort jesus loves you
and they never seen them again
no they ate that [ __ ] they
[ __ ] them probably and then they ate
them
they [ __ ] used him like a skin suit
my dude they saw that [ __ ] white skin
they probably [ __ ] skinned them alive
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] scary there's a headdress okay
that's what these savages do man say nah
leave them alone
i leave them alone but you don't kill
the [ __ ] now oh my god i'm gonna
get [ __ ] on the internet for this oh my
god
now we got in the morning following
fishermen watch for a distance as the
trashman drag close
body
oh [ __ ] yeah bro
yeah i don't just leave him alone no but
listen let him
watch them taking the stairs asparagus
coming at you i'm not
not going to know nowhere no no they
killed me
they killed seven people from the
history of it they killed a couple of
[ __ ]
and [ __ ] criminals floated over to try
to get away from the law and they [ __ ]
them up
yeah they just savaged mine
they don't got no schooling no nothing
they just straight on caveman time still
and i'm gonna beat their [ __ ] ass
when they bother me
no no [ __ ] that no listen put steve oh
show them that what was steve oh they
were violating steve oh you can't do
look at this man
y'all telling me you're gonna be
friendly with these no you gotta violate
them they gotta live under all law
limbo get medicine for when for they
don't die when they're in our presence
that's [ __ ] i don't want i don't
think people should be like that another
kill jay said
how are you going to dictate somebody's
happiness that's not happiness
no they don't know anything about
happiness look at this guy he was
steve uh he's a beautiful person but god
damn
these are real people they're so white
before they're about to eat his ass
oh steve is a sick man oh god he's
beautiful though because this is crazy
we gotta go back [ __ ] this oh you can't
imagine man can you imagine being
like that man what is stevo he's like in
some place with some place for some
indigenous people that's in india
yeah um oh this is
look what it do to the report almost
eaten by cannibals see that reporter
right there yeah this
is nice because this is crazy ah this is
crazy [ __ ] this is a piece of meat
oh this nasty pig look at this head this
necklace head thingy has on it's got
like human jaw bones on it
they setting you up [ __ ] this guy is
petrified
that's the skull
oh man this is you that's what you gonna
look like in two seconds
you just trying to give you yeah
this is really weird oh i like your
phone no you ain't seen nothing yet
yeah i know you think you're still
looking in the middle you're gonna turn
your head
that's where we come from we come from
these kind of guys and then there's some
stuff when you look at that man
originating from these kind of guys
us humanity comes from there
and we're taught to be like this that's
interesting we don't act like this we're
going to get punished
what the didn't they get what's this
[ __ ] gave him a bunch of jawbone yo
this is real people
yeah what's the and gory they're
cannibal
they're cannibals they're cannibals in
india
beat other people why are
people on that side of the river so
afraid of the agory
you [ __ ] jim are you going so he know
english
too no he has someone hear this
[ __ ] talking one of the guys
understanding me to interpret
somebody yeah at the director
let's see where it goes let's see where
it goes
oh [ __ ] what's it like oh
oh man this is the end is the best oh
man this is nasty [ __ ] what is that our
divine mother you are great
for everyone's wishes hell divine mother
hell lord
these guys don't got toilet paper dude
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] everybody said this i backed up
like the [ __ ] was like over here like yo
what the [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
he starts throwing it at them oh
[ __ ] that yeah
yeah yeah that's another level man
oh it's out there that's out there
brother bro
y'all need to stay off the internet man
way
way bizarre what y'all got going on man
oh
man why would they put that on there
dude
i don't know man that was cnn too yeah
that reporter goes out there dude it's
just crazy there's still places in this
world that's
really really still stuck in
the beginning of the time like that like
yeah
yeah it's like that island you know it's
crazy you know as time goes on i don't
know if it
ever happened because um
maybe it will you know this it's just
billions of dollars
stolen money is hitting in the world
that's a trip right
forget forget the holocaust money that's
in the
the nazi store just imagine napoleon and
all the pirates before those guys
the 1600s and nobody ever found most of
their treasure
it's crazy that's nuts
it's it's somewhere somebody got to find
out well eventually another hundred
years
all the forests and everything be cut
down because of uh
[ __ ] people um excavating
and making new cities and people run
into it it's a matter of time brother
jim have you ever watched the show no i
mean
no i haven't watched the show but uh
the other day i don't know what went on
it was all over ig
and that was the first time i was hip to
mike having having a show um and then
the next the next couple weeks they like
uh mike wants you to come to the show
like okay cool
yeah so [ __ ] fly we will still fly
well you're you're such an incredible
personality in hip-hop
no thank you and you've got some
story lines oh you're like i want to
[ __ ] get involved with your personal
[ __ ] that's all good man
it's all good man you know i'm an open
book well you have like
a pretty entertaining maybe not for you
i don't know but
back and forth with 50 cent yeah what's
up with that
man yeah you know he's 50
that's 50 right you know it's nothing
personal man even
uh having a hell of a fun competition
back and forth for years we support each
other
in weirdest way but you know it's it's
still left in line between
yeah friendly competition and aggressive
competition but you know shout outs to
50. congrats congrats to him and all his
successes
big 50 he got to go against this other
show what's the show that [ __ ] lead
down he's going against
let's do that let's leave daniel's show
remember the [ __ ] remember [ __ ] said
the [ __ ] whipped his ass and [ __ ]
him up and it wasn't what's that show
oh the jesse smaller show what's to show
you where he works
um what's the empire yeah yeah that's
the competition with 50.
and what's the 50 what's 50 show name
again power [ __ ] power
power versus empire yeah
that [ __ ] ass i think [ __ ] jesse
[ __ ] it up
yeah i [ __ ] it up [ __ ] powers back
right
beyond i think power came back
back to jesse [ __ ] lying and [ __ ]
yeah
and jesse got a lot of bad moves and
[ __ ] because he got political
clout yeah he got a bunch of
[ __ ] political [ __ ] love
jesse he got that off yeah he got
smaller he's smooth he's smooth
walk past that ass [ __ ] he got
no explanations no nothing nobody knows
what the [ __ ] happened
yeah it's over they got shut down
exactly exactly [ __ ] must not know his
name
i'm jesse [ __ ] yeah that's what
it is i mean it's jesse
jessie's saying more badass i know
jessie's better
okay you leaving us
you leave it at the event what event you
talking about what is that what are you
talking about
event today in beverly hills what are
they doing [ __ ] nice
to make an event listening it's crazy
what are you talking about
you tasting stuff like we got a
weed ball we got a cigar roller
pounds
mike's the man dude mike doesn't [ __ ]
around with business
you know i used to look at that like
that's like a [ __ ] hand that's
[ __ ]
but that's the only purpose you know to
be paid for your service the worst thing
could happen somebody
is preventing them from being the best
they could possibly be
and that you do that from not just
paying people for their services
you can prevent them from being at their
best they start to think that
they're not worthy of even though they
fighting as [ __ ] when they don't win the
bad
[ __ ] my worthy of it why is all this
happening to me why am i dealing with
twice they're not dealing with this [ __ ]
you know and then they they lose their
belief in themselves and once that
happens it's over
he's either dead or in prison some
[ __ ] way
that's why people shouldn't be you
shouldn't have be in a position to have
their spirit broken
you know someone takes them for you and
you you you're doing the right causes
getting their background he's in the
proper procedures
and it doesn't happen to be successful
he just doesn't
it takes a piece of you away you know
you've been in a bit you understand that
right takes a piece of you away
and you lose those battles sometimes
because you're battling for something
you say why am i even fighting for
something that's mine
somebody wants to just chip it away from
you fighting for your life
people chipping away from me why am i
fighting for pieces of myself
without from other people in a [ __ ]
courtroom
i'm fighting for percentages of my flesh
with another human being
and this court system is allowing that
to [ __ ] happen right now
another person is suing me for me pretty
much you know what i mean
you should be fighting for me you should
be performing for me while you
performing in that car
i had a contract even though the
contract's over you still should be with
me for some kind of [ __ ] reason
because that make up a law you know what
i mean
yeah i swear that i sweat a couple of
years i put in time for it's just all
[ __ ]
for your sweat and blood that's just
crazy that shouldn't even be
that shouldn't even be able to be in a
courtroom
you know yeah you're fighting a lawyer
uh
agent because of you he he believes he
owns parts of your
success or your existence your
likeliness of everything
yeah that's crazy person yeah you're
familiar with that kind of stuff yeah
yes
you're not a person no more yeah yeah
yeah enter your identity your name your
likeness
your [ __ ] image there's so many and
there's so many entertainers and
athletes are in court right now over
there oh yeah they're fighting somebody
over themselves
i know isn't that crazy hmm that's crazy
that's what oj with the jail for right
some people
some people some people come yeah some
people could lose their contract if they
ride a motorcycle because that's not
your body that's my body
yeah i don't i'm not gonna give you no
money you get pus as a position a
situation you can hurt yourself for
riding a bike
sometimes you have to stop your whole
life just to fulfill that contract
yeah you're no longer yourself yeah a
lot of them athletes can't do
sure you could barely play a certain
degree with your kids they might put
their finger in your [ __ ] eye start
playing
ain't none of something's crazy like
that yeah yeah well you know i had it
more no i know
yeah no you're right man a lot of nfl
player contracts have all
done like zombie contracts you can't get
it when you get it you're the [ __ ]
zombie
yeah there's an issue
a while ago with ben roethlisberger
riding a motorcycle he's going to
remember that's what i was talking about
yeah yeah he got hurt he got into a
motorcycle accident and then there's a
whole big deal
about his contract and you know they try
to
try to challenge out of trouble yeah so
i always bring that up i always bring
the most because of him
yeah interesting
can't your whole life you did this all
you before you even started sports you
were riding
and also why you can't do that no more
it's crazy can't go to church anymore
you know just basically yeah
jim what are you doing in l.a brother is
it for the event for the launch i'm here
for the saucy event then i was a
dude that's gonna be pretty awesome how
did you feel proud about doing this
right yes
my wife is so proud that i'm doing this
stuff you know what i mean that you know
um i guess that she's happy to see that
you can be versatile and people can
respect
you for another reason you know yeah
that's all
sometimes i say even though people say
hey man you did you did good in boxing
but i left with a bad taste and stuff a
lot of burnt bridges and stuff that's
why i never stayed with boxers they were
promoting and stuff
it wasn't a good thing it just wasn't
good so i got involved with
um this stuff and this just was i'm in
another world
totally um obsolete from those guys you
know i mean
you could be creative you could be
yourself yourself and i could be
more than i could ever been before
mm-hmm and just take you in a lot of
different directions
that necessarily ain't got to do with
anything you have to do a box or just
being like do you have other businesses
jim um yeah i'm heavy into fitness i
have a consult agency called a
consulting agency where i'm
helping a lot of musicians out trying to
uh
let them understand what the music
business is about help them get a fair
shot at um yeah
getting a career yeah i have a
consulting business i was telling alex
he told me people don't rappers don't
ask him for advice i said
you tell me no young guys could say man
what do i do now got a million dollars
what am i going to do
yeah 20 million dollars what did i do
now what did you do yeah doing the
accident i get the
that'd be the first thing i see a man
tell me what to do
i was like one of the hardest probably
rappers to even get next to this
thankful
question really not to say it like that
it's just that he's yeah
awkward big that you're not really going
to get next to him and he's not really
in the
in the rooms listen to me
listen the amigos drake they got yo ella
what happened man you hit the [ __ ]
when you got [ __ ] triple platinum
what did that what did you what was it
like what did you do
that's what i wanted always that fight
what did you do when you knocked out
such and said that was the biggest fight
of your life what did you do right after
did you go [ __ ] some girls or did you go
drink or did you get hot what did you do
right that moment after you knocked him
out and got dressed from the dress room
took your shot
what did you do what was your biggest
interest right there did you go right
and pick your money up did you go [ __ ]
your girl
do you get high what did you do right
after that i got a question for you oh
when you used to be flashing all that
cash they give you all your cash
oh that's just that's um what is it
that's a bad bet making somebody that's
um
every time i knock somebody out in the
first round i get um
how much what the [ __ ] with 200 thousand
dollars bonus your bonus
should i be the money be holding up yeah
this is just [ __ ] you money huh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you get girls [ __ ] get
jury [ __ ] go get it too but
most people are just giving this [ __ ]
away it's all giving this [ __ ] away he's
having fun balling can't
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] at the end of
the day what the [ __ ] did that [ __ ] go
and then you said [ __ ] this you
[ __ ] um
you may listen i went to my life saying
[ __ ] what happened to my [ __ ] money
all my [ __ ]
and then you run into another
[ __ ] they got me the man that
crazier than you yes boo boo no might
come with us and i think [ __ ] i'm i'm on
this ride again
and then you think you almost by the
time you finish with another couple of
years the [ __ ] is balling out of your
life
you're doing like um [ __ ] three
months on the [ __ ]
french riviera i'm going from ibiza
spain to [ __ ] moscow
on my friend's boat we just [ __ ]
bawling stopping in my lawn stopping in
greece picking up girls
boom dropping off picking up more
gracious boom doing drugs
[ __ ] up it's heavy oh it's just crazy
being stopped by the
by the [ __ ] boat police it's just
crazy holy [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
look at the distance ibiza spain to the
[ __ ] ukraine
because then we took a plane from the
ukraine to [ __ ] moscow we can't
do the boat to moscow to the ukraine how
big was the boat the boat was like 150.
ah but it was so crazy because we were
like savages we were like [ __ ]
pirates just trying to believe that
we're conquering these [ __ ] countries
and [ __ ]
we had [ __ ] like four different
[ __ ] you know
the crews of the ship come on but you
know the crew people that work this year
they would [ __ ] quit and then we had
to get more [ __ ] crews from other
people they said we can't take this
no more [ __ ] and man it was just like
[ __ ]
unbelievable i'm so happy i can't listen
when i started walking i couldn't walk
unless we were on water so long
we got to the ukraine and we got off and
i had to walk in the airport
i couldn't even walk my legs because
i've been in the water so long i would
rub my own
it was crazy three months on the [ __ ]
boat it's [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] up with the gravity yeah it's a
trip you'll be through you're in outer
space
you'll be surprised you're on the boat
for three months and then when it's time
to walk you
to walk off the boat y'all just was
staying on the boat we'd be in the boat
then we get off the boat and when i was
like just stay for sicily we stopped
assisting we get off the party assistant
hey come with us too so we get a little
boat
to drive to our big boat and they hang
out with us and then we go to greece and
they say well i have cousins in greece
anyway so they stay in greece
and then we party english then we grab
some girls from greece and then we go to
what's the other one
what oh what the [ __ ] not it could have
been was it romania
i don't know but it's just back and
forth man it's just crazy to talk about
he's just [ __ ] nuts
it seemed like those things like that
those are some good times
oh man those were [ __ ] like me just
living my [ __ ]
insane life with no [ __ ] um blinders
just going for it yeah not
caring about [ __ ] [ __ ] no lord
[ __ ] with me nothing i'm
god it's crazy
mike most times the internet doesn't
even have an
answer for your questions but uh
ibiza where'd you go to it was a
business thing first we started at the
beach of spain
yeah and then we made it to monaco then
we did um
central pay then we did what the [ __ ] is
san remo italy then we did
what's the best place you've been to the
place you had the most fun
listen it's a place in italy
what does it start with with all of us
it has the billionaire club there what's
the name of this place yeah that's the
best place that's pl it's
it's someone else please take it to the
southwest i mean dude you traveled
thousands of miles
on the south of france on the south of
france when this was the party time of
the year like in the summer the
spring of the summer it's just
incredible it's just the way they party
is just
um you have to see it to believe it
you just have to see it you know i mean
you see um
you see the most powerful people in the
world at their [ __ ] best and this is
how they play
you know the i call whoever was there
trump whoever is the most powerful
whoever with that person they're there
right now
and this is how they play they got 200
feet yards just
killing it picking them incredible both
yes see these both you say
these people are just showing off
because they have so much money it's
just too much if the [ __ ] i got too much
money they wanna
just buy a boat that's you know i don't
know what was the billionaire club
i don't know it's a place in italy i
forgot the name of it it was just um
it's been 100 200 on a [ __ ] magnum
magnum looks like this
it's just amazing yeah well mike don't
spend no money so i'm not spending
anyway and this is we'll buy it for you
underneath
the magnum is like two hundred thousand
dollars this is crazy how they spin
about [ __ ] magnum
champagne this is how they play
champagne
all night all night
yeah this is how they show off oh yeah
this is what we can do
it's crazy that's how people spend their
money
you know that [ __ ] bottle can help so
many people you know how many people in
africa
are in the poor neighborhood in brooklyn
how much is that bottle
i don't know it might be 250 000.
what's the [ __ ] place in this over
here it's [ __ ] oh man
250 thousand for the bottle
mulan no the naples no
oh my god in italy no
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
fresh riviera south of france spain
ibiza
yeah sardinia sardinia sardinia
now that's where the billionaire and i
was in there and so the guy
told me they might don't buy nothing
here the guy said our spots got
everything
right i thought the [ __ ] you mean you
know i'm just i guess
with these guys came up like i said i'm
just one of my little whole
party ride i'm thinking my life is over
and also i said mike where are you going
i said i don't know where i went
tonight's come on they come with me
and then i'm back to that [ __ ] again
everything's boom
the top of the hill and i'm saying [ __ ]
right so we had um
it was just it was just crazy it was
just really crazy it was just
i never lived like that before but i had
but everything was
it's just living everything it's going
full speed like you take your um
what is um your mower huh
and just let it run till it runs out
yeah that's how they lift
it's all out until they get tired pull
they fall out
it's a trip man
it's really um
you're just living dude they living to
die they're killing themselves that's
what it
is just going for it
bring them all
jim i got a question for you
we've been talking about this a lot
lately but uh
is it true that you were the originator
of love and hip-hop yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah they were the first ones well
that was actually my show premise that
was our name that was everything
um the person we got in
to business with she uh was just the
whole you know
so long ago and [ __ ] like that ramona
scott she capitalized off the whole
situation
and you wind up fighting for your life i
should have i should have
been a little bit smarter and um you say
we all got egos and sometimes we refuse
to compromise i i
can't do it together there's just a lot
of things that took place and you know i
go sometimes like i said before you
fighting for your life for the ownership
my likeness now
exactly you're fighting for your [ __ ]
right exactly
who is somebody to tell me that they own
a part of how i
live higher function
isn't that creepy [ __ ] yeah
hip hop man that's been a uh they had a
lot of success with that show so you
know
yeah i'm not one of the persons that
hate to be bitter about certain
situations and you know
everybody in life and time everything
comes to
everybody you know yeah i get what i
deserve all the time
i didn't worry about it i don't know i
think to myself i always um
i let things go you know i had a for a
long time i wanted to [ __ ]
physically get involved with people
because of things i believe that um
i was wronged and stuff and i used to
tear at me too but um
i'm glad i let that go you know i'm glad
i let that go
yeah i'm glad i got a lot of stuff for a
year for you before yesterday i'm like a
teenager
i was mad my life would be so totally
different
yeah there's a lot of relief in letting
go
yeah [ __ ] it's hard to hold on to a lot
of hate and pain
and resentment jim what else you got
going on these days brother
well i just were working man like yeah
so yeah just dropped the project um
we got the fitness thing moving i've
been uh we're admitted about fitness i'm
trying to get ready to open up a gym um
consulting agency uh saucy to marijuana
brand um
just trying to stay creative you know
you need to get back in shape and get
back in television and [ __ ] back and
doing your [ __ ]
you know reality your own shows and [ __ ]
now this
is all this faith it's all about you
giving energy believing in it you know
we could listen
a year ago i was [ __ ] up really bad i
was dealing with demons
a year ago just a year ago changed you
know i mean
i didn't feel like i wanted to live i
didn't want to live a year ago
now life is everything to me i got a
family my wife
we just had 10 years and stuff
but there was a rocky road oh god i'm
surprised i'm just very grateful she's
still with me
you know i'm the monster to live with
you know when you know my
um i don't have a wife or a [ __ ] wife
i have a wife or a prisoner
you know when i was in my addiction and
all my [ __ ]
it's kind of it's inconceivable people
could even stick with people that were
like that
you know i see people who are [ __ ]
addicts and i'm looking how could
anybody stick with people like that and
i think that's who i am
i really might be people i guess this is
people out there that does that stuff
god made those kind of people for the
people like us yeah i guess
those are special people those are
definitely special people
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah you did
yes it is what it is yes see life's
different
you know you look through the [ __ ] i got
all this [ __ ] now the [ __ ]
and then this [ __ ] is hey do you want
to wreck you i know that happens that
that you live i'm just [ __ ] almost
suicide we don't have nothing we're
[ __ ] the kids it's just
everything's almost over and the next
thing you know you gotta get hey man we
should open tyson wreck you want to open
type of record
how does that happen you know you guys
are your podcasts you got your show
you got the [ __ ] big corporation now
you got the big deal with these big
covers how does that [ __ ] happen like
it's the moment i was odin
and dying
you know this this is you know i mean
how to be just it's all about accepting
it's going to happen i'm not going to
fight like when i have all this boxing i
always say i don't deserve this [ __ ]
i'm a scumbag i hurt people i'm a rob
i'm a snatch nigga's chain i'm sticking
i don't deserve this [ __ ] you know
now i'm learning at this stage i'm
learning to accept this is who i am
this is the blessing that god gave me
you're blessed brother your whole life
been blessed
it's already written man yeah that's
what i think it's already written and
stuff
and it's all about being grateful and
stuff yeah
it's one of those interesting things
that
i know is true but
through that because the dangerous thing
about some
saying like it's already written is for
somebody to just go oh well i don't have
to [ __ ] do anything
no you definitely have to live right and
you have to be in action
yes you have to be in tune with with
your life no matter what if it's written
or not
yeah you [ __ ] it up yeah you know what i
mean absolutely this is what i found out
you know maybe i realized um
it's gonna be it's written what's gonna
happen but it's up to you how you're
gonna
look or be prepared when you meet that
you know when you meet your destiny
yeah you know you're going to be
prepared for your destiny when you meet
it
okay so you have to prepare now so when
you destiny come on the end of the game
you meet your destiny
this is how i look i prepared for it
you're not gonna be out of you won't be
out of whack you won't be
um predicted you know you won't know
what's not gonna happen you'll know
everything you're prepared for the
greatest moment of your life
that's how you just look at it yeah you
know yeah
everything that happens like when i went
when i used to eat meat and i didn't
like the way i felt
i like the way i felt when i'm taking
the [ __ ] [ __ ] was painful
and what the [ __ ] feels like somebody
put a [ __ ] blow torch to my ass
so i stopped eating like that someone's
like you like [ __ ] that no more
i'll be a vegan i'm going to eat them on
[ __ ] meat no more [ __ ] chocolate
and ice cream
and pizza and all that [ __ ] comfort
get high food
well mike you know most people
that shit's happening to them and in
this
culture go oh i need to go to the doctor
to get a pill for that
rather than saying oh why don't i change
up my lifestyle
and how i treat my body and my mind well
we're addicted to the doctor
right you know we're all addicted to the
doctor and we um
we don't understand that yet
we don't know why we're addicted why we
keep going to guys i guess that's why
we're addicted
to them huh it's cause of the error i
mean we just raised it
you know it's different errors like the
what's going on now is we're different
from you coming you was raised to do the
work
yeah you're out of shape you gotta get
up and get into shape yeah
stop eating certain things if you know
what i mean if you got diabetes then you
know you got to stop eating sugar so you
could try to beat the dog be like
nowadays like you said you got a pill
or put me on the knife i'm too fat i'm
gonna go get liposuction and yeah
i mean like it's yeah listen man listen
some of my listen
listen i'm gonna tell you man some of my
friends got liposuction now
and for a minute i was away and i looked
after this smile i was jealous
i said [ __ ] but that's a [ __ ] imma
savage it on me it's work out [ __ ] it
i'm gonna starve myself i'm not gonna
eat no more i'm just gonna be a vegan
eat some [ __ ] twigs and [ __ ] i'm not
even no more [ __ ] icing that no
[ __ ]
anything can give you a [ __ ] calorie
if you can get a calorie for me i'm not
gonna [ __ ] eat it
and that's just how i live my life right
now for [ __ ] what six months to [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that's the warrior's way bro
yeah
you know i don't know that's it that's
what it is
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ] pissed me off
and made me get like well i said
[ __ ]
must got balls like this because they
start cutting and sucking on me i'ma
scream like a [ __ ]
pig [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i haven't told myself i think
you're right there for this [ __ ]
god if you let somebody suck up listen
when that shit's sucking out listen when
this [ __ ] is sucking out organs
you don't know what's sucking he can't
he can't say stop hey you don't belong
in here let's put that
[ __ ] out no all that [ __ ] is sucking up
oh [ __ ] they got balls to do
that
[ __ ] i'm not doing that brother whoa
wait just exercise and eat right i'm
gonna be a pig i'm gonna be a musical
[ __ ] my wife's gonna hate my
[ __ ] gut
for a [ __ ] year and this is everybody
gonna say i'm a [ __ ]
savage but this is how it's gonna be no
[ __ ] way
they ain't sucking my guts out imagine
sucking all your [ __ ] gizzas and guts
are you miserable though huh are you
miserable no look when i'm starving yeah
i'll be miserable i'm a [ __ ]
sometime but hell no i'd rather
listen and i'm not judging people but
it's just this [ __ ]
um i got the secret i know in order to
accomplish your goals you have to suffer
almost dying yeah die
just gotta die if you don't like this no
i don't like i don't want to be i hate
this i
want to die rather this is the thing you
rather look like that the rest of your
life or you'd rather be dead i'd rather
be [ __ ] dead
and i know by doing this i'm not going
to [ __ ] die i might get close to it
but it's not going to kill me
and it's better than being dead
well that's the remedy for life
that's he's doing it i'm gonna [ __ ]
drive myself for the gym now
[ __ ] man well now it's been great man
jim
i appreciate appreciate you being here
bro what are you going are you going to
the [ __ ]
party i'm gonna go i'm gonna go get get
dressed and then i'm gonna go to this uh
to this event and have some fun smoke
some weed eat some food
now you're going by yourself with your
boys right
yeah we all it should be a few people
there man yeah
nice little list rsvp i had a great time
man all right thanks brother i enjoyed
this is bucket list for me to be in the
room
thank you brother we had a one on one
thank you yeah thank you man but hey man
you need a shout out
album together called floss and sauce
should be coming out of september
juelz is a currently you know he had a
little uh yeah why are they talking
about him being extorted
but you don't want to tell what's going
on
none of that's going on no extortion and
no bullying he's actually doing pretty
good he's getting his weight up he got
his complexion together he's looking
good you know what i mean yeah jail
saved my life
you know when i was in prison those
three years and saved my life i was
living just [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
unconsolable savage i was just had no
[ __ ] idea what's going on
yeah so for them waiting for him to come
home man he ha he's he has a baby that's
about to be born so you know he's a new
baby yeah he has a lot to look forward
to when he gets out so you know
how many kids you got cuz i watched the
show too i look at [ __ ] love and
hip-hop for me i got one
of him he has two three
whether before five kids he about to
have all together
right five or four five five i have
seven
you have seven yeah i had weighed eight
one passed away but i had
eight yes seven he got four he got four
i believe four of this
yeah juju little jewels his daughter
beautiful man yeah and listen my kids
[ __ ] yeah you know my kids are wild too
my kids are [ __ ] i don't even talk to
my kids
my son is aggressive he's very
aggressive like his father so
he's trying to trying to gauge it man
but it's been real i'm headed out to
this event
thanks brother all right thank you for
giving me your presents keep smoking
good
you're real man thank you for the gift i
hope you enjoyed it enjoy your videos
all right mike great episode late [ __ ]
coming in that's uh that's my little
cousin
hey everybody check out
hotboxingpodcast.com for
the latest other than that don't hurt me
peace
[Music]